now i understand that you're
just over the top talented straight from
the dome freestyler
that's a big setup
i do freestyle like i feel like
yeah talk to me about like actually just
coming up with like if i were to
give you um
a uh
just a topic a couple topics you would
be able to weave them into a free stuff
yeah the thing with freestyling is it's
not like riding a bike like
you
i could probably do okay and then
sometimes i trip up and i do bad and you
slip up and it's just kind of like when
you're when i'm done with it i've been
freestyling for a long time when i'm
done with the freestyle like it's always
assorted my my feeling about it is
always assorted sometimes i'm like that
was so whack i [ __ ]
did horribly let me do one to make up
for it or like oh that was pretty good
or like
like i feel like when i'm stoned i i'm
the best because
the way my brain multitasks words i feel
like is the best when i'm like a little
bit baked are you a little baked now no
oh damn it but i feel like i you know
like if you put out
i'll do it i'm not i'm never scared to
freestyle if you gave me a topic or two
i could try to put some words together
paul's a an unbelievable musician well
cool he's that just come out with his
first album nice it's uh it's called
that kid is you it's it's
like
really [ __ ] impressive um thanks dude
what about uh
okay how about the topic is
like
you know
i i'm just saying that paul briskey is
very attractive
okay he's in poverty he's missing um
paul briskey yeah paul briskey that's
right paul briskey i want to get frisky
i'll suck your dick i don't need no
whiskey cause you're kind of cute i want
to put two in your poop chute that's my
two fingers i got zingers oh my god i
got bees on my head no stingers
yeah yeah yeah
are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah
i said no mixed feelings about that that
was solid as [ __ ]
i'm feeling good about that with eye
contact too which i appreciate
dude i'm blushing over here thank you
i mean thank you for that brother
that was uh
that that was that was a big honor i
just i was like man i'm gonna put him on
the spot what's the most what's the most
nervous you've ever been to freestyle
like oh like i'm in front of method band
or something like that so i actually ran
to methamphetamine while i was streaming
and i did see that where in new york no
in uh in l.a on fairfax or something
right yeah he was like singing my theme
song and i'm like this is a [ __ ]
honor bro this guy like i'm the biggest
wu tank fan like my top three favorite
rap groups of all time i think
wu tang trap call quest and probably
like nwa
like and you know there's so many good
groups like bowling thugs and [ __ ] but i
feel like wu tang is definitely
probably like my number one um but my my
most nervous
time freestyling so like i came up
because jimmy kimmel found me on the
internet he found super super bowl game
yeah
so i was
doing his show for a while
and he just was learning about me he
just saw my little weird videos but he
didn't really see
any rap videos i don't think and so i
was in the alley like outside of his
show
freestyling for some random people i was
probably drunk or something and he came
out to like leave and he heard it and he
goes that's really good
and then the [ __ ] next day or two
days later
i'm on as a guest announcer and [ __ ]
shaquille o'neal is like
the guest
and live on [ __ ] tv he's like
oh i heard shaquille you you had a rap
album you know
our announcer over there andy he's a
he's a freestyle rapper too andy why
don't you give them some freestyle lines
like i got a freestyle to shaquille
o'neal and it's on tv so if i wow
how much of a chance do you have you
spit four bars and if they suck they're
just gonna go to the next segment you
know what i mean i don't really have
time to like try to do good or try to
save it well i didn't give you any time
yeah too true
i
did okay i did okay i wasn't like i
murdered that [ __ ] dog but like i did
okay i was like thank god i had words i
didn't slip up i rhymed without being
like uh uh uh so i was like i was like
okay i'll give myself a pass on that
good epic man getting anybody realizing
that it's genuinely coming out of thin
air is gonna
have it have like
a lower bar so are you surprised how
many rappers don't actually freestyle
off the top of the head oh they just
call everything a freestyle on the radio
yo yo we got so-and-so
here and he's here to freestyle and it's
just all written verses yeah of course
and then someone will actually freestyle
so it's not as good as the written one
and people like oh that was kind of
whack but like he's the only dude that
actually really did it i could i i
there's like 99.9 of the time i could
tell if it's a freestyle or not when you
have like metaphors and like crazy
references and it flows together
perfectly
99.9 of the time that [ __ ] is not off
the head who's the best freestyler
um little dicky
well that his was written on his wrist
little dicky's a dope rapper but he
doesn't
like there's a guy named idea who passed
away a long time ago who used to battle
eminem and he was like [ __ ] one of
the best of all time idea what about
that guy that walks around venice and he
gets three words
shout out to harry mack true true i will
never not respect harry mack's freestyle
ability he's one of the best living i
think it's the best rap you've ever
heard in your entire life and it's
that's freestyle right yeah i mean i
don't know i don't know if it's the best
rap i've heard in my life but freestyle
wise like [ __ ] like 10 out of 10.
he's up there off the top of the head 10
out of 10.
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
bye